[MUSIC PLAYING]
LOGAN URY: We're
very lucky to have
Mandy Len Catron, an expert on
modern romance, here with us
today.
Mandy is a professor at the
University of British Columbia,
and she writes a
relationship advice
column for online
magazine "The Rumpus."
Now, raise your hand if
you've heard of the famous 36
questions from Mandy's wildly
popular New York Times Modern
Love essay, "To Fall in
Love with Anyone, Do This."
And keep your hand
raised if you've actually
gone through and answered
these 36 questions.
Great.
So we have a few
people in the audience.
So it seems like many of you
are familiar with this idea.
And for those of you who haven't
heard of it, in the essay,
Mandy describes a date she
went on with an acquaintance.
They tried a
20-year-old psych study
which was designed to
make people fall in love.
They answered a series of
36 increasingly personal
questions, such as, when's
the last time you cried.
This was followed by four
minutes of eye contact.
She and her date ultimately
did fall in love,
and yes, they are
still together today.
So, Mandy, thank you
so much for joining us.
MANDY LEN CATRON:
Thanks for having me.
LOGAN URY: By the way,
I'll leave 15 minutes
at the end for questions
from the audience.
So, Mandy, your
new book of essays
"How to Fall in
Love with Anyone"
is about how love stories shape
our ideas about love, sometimes
in unproductive and
misleading ways.
Let's start there.
What's the problem
with love stories?
MANDY LEN CATRON:
Well, I mean, I
think there are a lot of
problems with love stories,
actually.
I first started
thinking about this--
when I was 26, my parents
sat my sister and I down
and they were like, we don't
love each other anymore;
we're getting a divorce.
And I was really shocked.
I didn't know that
anything was less
than perfect in
their marriage, and I
had a really hard
time just, like,
coming to terms with this.
And I started
thinking about why.
And one of the things
that I came up with
was that divorce felt
like the wrong ending
to their love
story, And I started
thinking about all the ways
in which love stories had
shaped me, like most of my
ideas about romantic love.
And I began to feel
like, you know,
maybe I don't know very
much about love at all.
And so I just started
doing lots of research,
and very quickly I was like this
topic, which is basically just
like the gap between
how we talk about love
and how we actually
practice it--
and I mean, everything
from romantic comedies
to the stories we
tell each other
about our own relationships
to the stories we
inherit from our families--
that this gap was big enough
to become the subject of a book
basically.
And so that's what I did.
LOGAN URY: And now
we have your book.
MANDY LEN CATRON: Yeah.
But I guess the short
answer to your question
is essentially love stories
suggest that there's
a right way to practice love
and that if you practice it
that way then you'll be happy.
And I think that often--
really often-- that's just not
the case, that actually love
is a lot more
complicated than that.
LOGAN URY: So speaking
of being complicated,
in your book and essays, you
say that the 36 questions are
compelling because they
create vulnerability
and the chance for people
to connect and feel
known, yet many people
have understood them to be
a guaranteed to produce love.
Ironically, despite
your hesitations
around love stories,
your life has been viewed
as the ultimate love story.
How do you reconcile
your intention
in writing the
36-question piece with how
people have interpreted it?
MANDY LEN CATRON: Yeah,
it's really strange.
It's been a strange experience.
I think I started writing this
book about five years before I
published the article
in the New York Times.
And so I had been thinking
like really long and hard
about the role of love
stories in our culture,
and one of the things
that always bothered
me is that I felt like people
really wanted a simple story
and they liked sort of a really
clean and tidy narrative.
And it was very strange,
then, to basically watch,
because this article
was published.
And I think within a
month it had gotten, like,
8 million views, which is crazy.
And so I was reading about my
own relationship in the news,
and people would
say things like,
they fell in love by
the end of the evening
or this is how she
met her husband.
And none of those
things were true.
We did the questions.
We started dating probably
three months later,
and we had only been
dating for, like,
four months when the
article was published.
LOGAN URY: No pressure.
MANDY LEN CATRON: Yeah.
So it was really strange.
And the other thing that
was interesting to me
is that people would say--
and when I say people, I
mean journalists, but also I
spoke to a couple of
editors about the book--
and everybody would ask the
same question, which is, are you
guys still together.
And when I said yes,
they were like, oh,
my God, that's so great.
And it was great,
but I felt like there
were much more interesting
things to say about it.
But people didn't care.
They didn't want to hear that.
They just want to
know that it worked.
LOGAN URY: But people must come
up to you and say, I tried it,
and we didn't fall in love.
MANDY LEN CATRON: Yeah,
they have said that.
And I'm like, that's because
there is no guarantee that
doing this equals
romantic love, but it
does seem pretty good
at creating closeness.
So I think going into
it with that in mind
is maybe a better
way to approach it.
But I've realized
that it really doesn't
matter what I say about this.
The study has taken
on a life of its own
that is sort of
separate from me.
LOGAN URY: So in your
book, you discuss
unconventional
relationships that we
don't hear about in love
stories like "Cinderella"
or romantic comedies
like "Notting Hill."
You live in Vancouver,
we're here in the Bay Area,
and these are places
where different types
of relationships
are more accepted.
In fact, my boyfriend and I
joke that in San Francisco
we have to come out to
our friends as monogamous.
[LAUGHTER]
What would be your
advice for people
who are unfamiliar with
unconventional relationships,
such as open marriages?
And what would you say for
people watching this online who
live somewhere where
those partnerships are
more stigmatized?
MANDY LEN CATRON:
Yeah, I mean, so one
of the things that I found when
I was researching this book
is that many love stories
have the effect of really
just narrowing our sense of
what love can look like and sort
of channeling it into this
like dominant practice of love.
And that practice is what I call
the love-marriage-baby carriage
trajectory.
Because ultimately love is
a biological experience,
but it's also very social.
And what we do with those
biological sorts of impulses
is very much channeled by
the culture that we live in.
And so most of the stories
we consume I think really,
like I was saying
earlier, suggest
that this is the way to be
happy and that if you're not
practicing love this way
then you're sort of failing.
But actually, if you look at
the history of romantic love
and the history of marriage, one
of the things you'll discover
is that love and
marriage have only
been very tightly
interconnected for, like,
the past 200 or so years.
And so this idea that
we think is normal
and maybe even universal, which
is that you find one person
and you want to spend the
rest of your life with them
and you have this intense
passionate love forever,
is really a fairly new idea
in the history of humanity.
So I think it's interesting
to think about it that way.
And once you start
thinking about it that way,
you realize there are actually
lots of different ways
to practice love.
And so one of the
things that I found
is that what I wanted
from a love story changed
a lot over the course of writing
the book, and by the time
I got to the end of
the process, what
I found is that it was much
more interested in stories
that sort of widened our
sense of what love could be.
And those would be
things like stories
about non-monogamous
relationships,
queer relationships, even
stories about relationships
that are short but
meaningful, like something
that doesn't last your whole
life but still is important.
And so anything where
we sort of approach
love with a real
complexity and look
for what makes it meaningful in
our lives instead of thinking
about how it's supposed to be--
those kinds of
stories, I think, are
the kinds of stories that we
should all be seeking out more.
And I think the
advantage of looking
for those kinds of stories
is that, ultimately, you
have a broader sense of
possibility of what love might
look like, and then you
have a better chance
of creating the kinds of
relationships in your life
that work for you,
which I think is great.
LOGAN URY: So what
would your advice
be for somebody who
maybe hasn't had success
with monogamous relationships
or is like, oh, what
else is out there, I don't
see a lot of examples of that?
MANDY LEN CATRON: Yeah, and
non-monogamy I sometimes
feel like is like
the final frontier
of romantic relationships
in our culture,
because it is so stigmatized.
But I do think that's changing.
A good friend of mine wrote this
great book called "What Love Is
and What It Could Be."
And her name is Carrie Jenkins,
and she's a philosopher at UBC.
And she really thinks about
the biological science
of romantic love
and how that sort
of relates to our
social impulses
for what love looks like,
and she essentially suggests
that it is possible to change
our ideas about romantic love
but that it takes
time and practice
and opening ourselves
up to new possibilities
for how it might be practiced.
So I would recommend that
people read her book,
because I think it's great.
LOGAN URY: It's interesting.
So you mentioned new ways
for love to be practiced.
I really enjoyed your
newest Modern Love
essay, which was about Mark and
Mandy's relationship contract.
And it includes commitments
for the next 12 months
of a relationship, such as how
he'll do chores, save money,
and even have sex.
For some people,
there's nothing less
sexy than signing a contract,
yet you called the experience
empowering.
Tell us more about why
you created this contract
and how it's changed
your relationship.
MANDY LEN CATRON:
So basically, one
of the nice things about
writing about romantic love
is that people send you things
all the time, like articles
and books and whatever.
People, once they know
you're interested in it,
they are always sharing ideas
with you, which is great.
So one of the things
that a friend of mine
sent me was this book called
"The New I Do," and it was just
ways of re-conceptualizing
marriage.
And in it, she had a chapter
called "The Starter Marriage."
And basically the idea was
that you would have a two year
marriage and you
would sign a contract,
and then at the end
of that two years
you could decide if you really
wanted to be with this person.
And Mark and I were
reading it fairly early
in our relationship
and we both thought
it was an interesting idea.
And so then a year
after that, we
were trying to decide whether
or not to move in together,
and I think we both had a
lot of anxieties about it.
And for me--
I feel like I can only really
speak for myself here--
but my anxieties were
really to do with the fact
that I was in a long
relationship from age 20 to 30,
and then when I got out
of that relationship,
one of the things
that I discovered
that was so amazing
about being single
was just being like fully
in charge of my own time.
And I just had no idea
how great that would be.
And I was scared that once I
started living with someone
again that I would give that up.
Because I think I
have this tendency
to sort of like really deeply
invest in my relationships,
which is not a bad thing.
And so I wanted some way to
feel like there would be space
for me in my own relationship.
And so Mark actually suggested,
hey, what about that contract
thing that we read about?
And so we sat down one night
a week before he moved in,
and we just went over
everything, everything
that we could think of.
And a lot of people
think, oh, my God.
A lot of the comments
in the New York
Times in response to
this article was like,
are you guys robots?
It sounds so cold-hearted
and calculating,
but it's really not at all.
It's really about
the spirit of things.
So the sex part people
were very concerned about.
It's really just like,
this is an important part
of our relationship.
It's something we
both value, and we
agree that we're going
to be monogamous for now.
But we want it to be open to
changing that, because we want
to be open to changing
everything, I guess,
and acknowledging
that people do change
and that our needs change.
And there's something I
think so nice about that,
because I just
really felt heard.
And I never felt heard in a
relationship quite like that
before and that
my needs mattered,
and I think probably that was
great for both of us, which
is nice.
LOGAN URY: What are some other
things you included that maybe
would have been
awkward to bring up
outside of writing a contract?
MANDY LEN CATRON: Well,
one of them is marriage.
So I talked about that.
Because it sort of
came out one night
that he felt a lot of pressure
to decide to get a ring
and do a proposal, and I
got really upset about this.
And I think that
was because I felt
like we had been so intentional
about so many things
in our relationship.
It just seemed to me
weird that this would be
a decision that he made alone.
And so that was like a month
before we renewed our contract.
So then, when we sat
down to renew it,
we just said, OK, what do
you think about marriage
and is this something
we want to do?
And it was really nice just to
have a really open conversation
about it.
I mean, I should be honest.
It helps that it's my job
to think about these things.
So it's much easier to bring
them up in conversation
because I'm thinking
about them all the time.
Because we're always trying
to practice, because he's
really a good sport.
So I'm always was
like, oh, I read this
about the research of
romantic love today.
Recently, I think John
Gottman said when you got home
and you greet your partner
at the end of the day,
you should kiss for six seconds.
So I told him this, and
so he's like, OK, cool,
let's do it, which is great.
LOGAN URY: Yeah,
along similar lines,
I was listening to the Tim
Ferriss podcast recently,
and Esther Perel was on, the
couple's therapist and author.
And she said, quote,
"Every other system gets
innovation, new ideas,
curiosity, inventiveness.
Coupledom doesn't benefit from
the same innovative spirit
that every other company
and entrepreneurial space
benefits from."
So I'd certainly say that your
relationship contract is a more
innovative approach to love.
What are some of the
other original ideas
or love hacks that
couples may use
to improve their relationships?
MANDY LEN CATRON: I
love that she said this.
I hadn't heard this quote.
It's so good.
Yeah, there are lots of
things that you can do.
So one of the things that
we do that I really like
is that we have a
monthly date night.
So it's like the first
week of every month,
and the rule is that we
take turns planning it.
LOGAN URY: This goes back to
the emotional labor thing.
MANDY LEN CATRON: Yep.
Whoever plans it
also pays for it,
and the other person doesn't
know anything about what we're
doing, except the day it is.
And then they just
sort of go along.
So everything is a surprise.
So it's really fun
first of all, but it
is backed up by research.
So there's this thing
called the misattribution
of arousal, which is
also by Arthur Aaron, who
did the 36 questions.
So he did this study
where basically--
and it just so happens
to be done in Vancouver.
And I think this was also
back in the 90s or maybe early
2000s.
But there's this huge
suspension bridge.
And so what he did is he had
this like attractive woman who
is his research assistant stand
at the end of the suspension
bridge, and when men
cross the bridge--
and I don't know how
far it is down, just
like hundreds of feet--
she would ask them
a few questions,
just say, oh, I'm doing a study.
And then she would
write her phone number
on the corner of the
paper and tear it off
and say, if you have
any questions, call me.
So she did that
there and then she
also did it at the end of
just a regular walk way.
And what they found
was that people
who had crossed the bridge were
statistically significantly way
more likely to call her.
And so what they think is that
this physiological arousal--
so increased heart
rate and sweaty palms,
which is also what happens
when you fall in love--
happens when you do something
new or scary or interesting.
And so we tend to
attribute those feelings
to the people that we're with
instead of to what we're doing.
So there's real value,
basically, in novelty.
So our role for date
night is that we
have to do something we
wouldn't normally do.
And it's fun because
it's just fun,
but there is a suggestion
that doing new things
together increases
your dopamine levels
and activates your
reward system and helps
keep you feeling attracted
to your partner, which
is interesting.
LOGAN URY: Yeah, I
actually remember
hearing about that psych
study in intro to psych class.
MANDY LEN CATRON: Yeah,
it's a popular one.
LOGAN URY: Then the
professor made a joke like,
that's why you should take
your date to see a scary movie.
MANDY LEN CATRON: Really?
This is so funny.
LOGAN URY: Your
adrenaline will spike,
and then you'll be
like, I must really
like the person I'm with.
MANDY LEN CATRON: So this is
funny because a friend of mine
is a psychology professor, and
he used this to meet his wife.
He took her to a scary movie.
LOGAN URY: It works.
MANDY LEN CATRON: And
now they're married.
And he always tells his
students about this.?
LOGAN URY: Yeah, we'll
have to chat about this.
What are some of the
novelties that you do?
I think all of this
is great fodder.
MANDY LEN CATRON: Oh, man.
We have done all
kinds of things.
We went on a long bike
ride to a part of town
we've never been to before.
We went to a burlesque show.
We went wine tasting.
Gosh, I'm blinking.
But we've done all kinds
of fun stuff in the city.
And we went to the opera--
yeah, and just like things
that I wouldn't make time
to do during my regular life.
LOGAN URY: So it sounds like
it's carving out that time,
taking turns planning, and
then really emphasizing
that it's novel.
MANDY LEN CATRON: Yeah, exactly.
LOGAN URY: Great.
So I know from your book,
and you mentioned it now,
that one of the reasons
you started researching
the topic of love stories
is because your parents got
divorced after
decades of marriage.
On the topic of
divorce, Louis C.K.
has said, "Divorce
is always good news.
I know that sounds
weird, but it's true
because no good marriage
has ever ended in divorce."
Now that you've spent the
last 10 years debunking
love stories, how do
you feel when you hear
a couple is getting divorced?
MANDY LEN CATRON: I
feel a deep empathy
because I know it's hard,
but I mean, sometimes
I do feel excited
for the people.
This sounds horrible.
Like a friend of mine--
so it wasn't a divorce,
but a friend of
mine had had sort
of an on-again, off-again
relationship with this woman
for a long time.
And he called me
one day, and he's
like, we finally ended things.
And I was like, congratulations.
And he was like, I'm
feeling really sad.
I felt so bad.
I was like, I'm so sorry.
LOGAN URY: Is that because
you didn't like the person?
MANDY LEN CATRON: No,
it was because I just
felt like it was the
right thing for him to do
and it had been hard.
And I just felt like it
was going to open him up
to a better relationship.
And I think because
I really went
through a similar
experience where
I was in a long-term
relationship with someone
that I like really,
really loved,
but we argued constantly.
And it was a real
struggle to decide
whether or not to stay in
that relationship, which
I think also motivated me
to do all this research.
Because there aren't a lot of
stories about people deciding
to end a pretty good, but not
great relationship, and now
there is.
But I think because
I knew how much that
was a great experience for
me ultimately in the end.
But yeah, divorces
are hard, and I
think the thing about divorce,
as opposed to just a breakup,
is that it comes in
a lot more shame.
Because it still has a
lot of social stigma.
I mean, I think we're getting
more accustomed to it,
but nobody--
I shouldn't say nobody--
very few people enter into
this kind of commitment
expecting it to end.
So you not only have to
deal with like the loss
of that relationship
and your partner,
and there is research that
shows going through a breakup
is like going through
cocaine withdrawal,
like neurochemically.
Like, your brain looks the
same to an fMRI machine.
So, like, it sucks,
so I get that.
Yeah.
LOGAN URY: So do you
actually have a lot of people
reaching out to you saying,
I'm in a good, but not great
relationship, what should I do?
MANDY LEN CATRON: I got an
email about this yesterday.
LOGAN URY: What are
you going to reply?
MANDY LEN CATRON: I don't know.
It's really tough so often.
And they're like strangers.
They're not like people I know.
And so often I want
to be like, you
should end the relationship.
People in the
audience are gasping.
Because I do think that there
are 7 and 1/2 billion people
in the world, and
I think there are
any number of people
that you could
have a great relationship with.
And so there's this term
by this philosopher named
Elizabeth Brake called
"amato normativity,"
and the idea is
that in our culture
we tend to presume that it is
better to be in a relationship
and ideally a long-term
committed relationship
than to not be in
a relationship.
And I love this word, because I
feel like this idea is so true
but we never talk about it.
And now that we have a word for
it, it's easier to talk about.
But I think the
truth is, it's not
better to be in a
mediocre relationship
than it is to be single.
LOGAN URY: We should put
that on a banner somewhere.
MANDY LEN CATRON: Yeah,
put on the Google homepage.
LOGAN URY: There we go.
Someone here may be
able to help with that.
MANDY LEN CATRON: Yeah,
but it's not better.
Being single can be so
great, and I don't think
we acknowledge that enough.
So I don't know.
I always want to be like, you
should leave that relationship,
but I know that if I had
gotten that advice myself,
I would not have taken it.
LOGAN URY: But it also
feels like they're
coming to you for it, sort of
like they want you to bless
leaving the relationship.
MANDY LEN CATRON: Yeah.
And you know what?
I do, though.
I got this email from this
girl and she was really young,
and she was with her
high school boyfriend
and they had graduated college.
And she wanted to live a
different life than him.
And I said, do you
want me to give you
permission to break his heart?
Because I will.
You'll both be
better off for it.
And she emailed me
back six months later,
and she was like, that
was the right thing to do,
which is pretty cool.
LOGAN URY: Yeah.
That's great.
I think for the
rest of your life,
people will come to
you with these issues.
MANDY LEN CATRON:
I think so, too,
and I just want to
be clear, sometimes
I do not know the answer
to these questions.
But this is why I started
the advice column,
because I felt like
that was a better way
to sort of deal with this than
responding to personal emails.
Because I don't know.
It feels like a lot
of responsibility.
LOGAN URY: You
should all check out.
It's on therumpus.net, and I
think you've done two so far.
And they're great.
They're very research-backed.
So it's not just
somebody saying, here's
what happened to me.
It's saying, well,
researchers who
are in the space of
philosophy and psychology
and romantic relationships
have found this.
MANDY LEN CATRON:
And this is what
I like about it, because I feel
like so much advice is just
someone's intuition.
And I just don't trust
my intuition that much.
So instead I'm like, let me
do some research for you,
and that's fun because I
learn a lot in the process.
LOGAN URY: That's great.
So you're very
passionate about the idea
that love stories perpetuate
a mystical and unrealistic
quality to love.
If you could design a
class, either in high school
or online, that every
person would be required
to take before entering
into adult relationships,
what would you
include in the course?
MANDY LEN CATRON: Oh, my
gosh, this is so interesting.
So I sort of teach
a course like this,
and it's not actually
meant to be practical.
Because I teach
first-year composition,
which is just like, here's
how to write a research paper.
And that can be about anything.
So I just use all the research
that I came across in my book,
and so we read a lot of
articles about romantic love.
And then I have them write
a research paper about love,
which is really fun.
But often I feel like
I'm just puncturing
the romantic illusions
of 18- and 19-year-olds,
and I feel conflicted
about that.
Mostly I feel good about it.
I think what I would
like everyone to do,
or what everyone
should do, is just
think long and hard about the
stories that have influenced
your ideas about romantic love
and think about the scripts
that they contain.
There are these
sociologists who have
this theory that basically all
human knowledge is contained
in stories, and so they
talk about these scripts.
And there can be like
a macroscript, which
is the role of love over the
course of your life, which
is this love-marriage-baby
carriage thing.
But there are also
these micro scripts,
which is just like, what
to say on a first date.
And these scripts
basically are very useful,
because they help
us figure out how
to interact with other people.
But I think so often we
take these scripts to heart,
and it's nice to look at
the scripts that really have
probably influenced you over the
years and step back from them
and say, which ones do these
do I actually want to practice
and which one of these
am I not so sure about
and do I want to reject?
And that's been a
useful exercise for me.
LOGAN URY: What are some of
the ones that you've rejected?
MANDY LEN CATRON: So
one of the biggest ones
is this idea that love is
equated to deservingness,
which really bothers me.
So this is the idea in pretty
much any Cinderella story.
So I write a lot about
Cinderella stories
and in particular the
movie "Pretty Woman."
We had this on VHS at home
when I was growing up,
and my sister and I would watch
it when we were really little.
I think I was 10
and she was six.
And we watched "101 Dalmatians"
and we watched "Aladdin"
and we'd watch "Pretty Woman."
And I think of the ideas that
I absorbed, but really it's
like there's a
powerful man and then
there's a woman of
really low social status.
And basically, all Cinderella
stories have this narrative,
and it's like she waits for
someone important to notice
her and choose her.
And in Cinderella stories,
the woman is always chosen--
the genders can be reversed,
but typically it's a woman--
chosen because she's like
fundamentally good somehow.
And in "Pretty Woman,"
the great example of this
is where she's in the bathroom
of their penthouse suite
and Richard Gere thinks
she's like doing drugs,
and he grabs her arm and
tries to kick her out.
And he opens her hand,
and it's dental floss.
So this is like 1990, which is
like the DARE era, where drugs
are the worst thing
a person can do
but oral hygiene is so great.
So it's like, oh,
yeah, she's actually
a really good person who just
stumbled into this bad job--
but so this idea, which is,
like, some people deserve love
and if you are good then
someone will notice you.
And you don't have to do
anything but just be good,
and they'll choose you.
And then you'll have the life
you've always dreamed of.
And this story is so common,
and it's in "Dirty Dancing"
and it's in "Pretty
Woman" and it's
in all the different
versions of "Cinderella."
It's in "Titanic," even,
with the genders reversed,
but I think it's a real problem.
And it really implies,
especially for women,
that the most important
moment of your life, the most
validating experience is
being chosen by someone
important or interesting.
And I hate that idea.
LOGAN URY: It seems like
there's two problematic issues.
One is it implies that if
you're good, you'll be chosen.
So if you're not chosen,
then you weren't good.
MANDY LEN CATRON: Yeah.
LOGAN URY: And it
also seems like it's
a very passive approach
to finding your partner.
MANDY LEN CATRON:
Yeah, and I think
it's important to
point out the inverse,
that if you're not chosen then
you're not good, which I think
is really related to the stigma
of being single in our society.
Single people have great
lives, and yet the implication
is like, oh, you
must be miserable
or, oh, you must be
doing something wrong.
And sometimes that's
just not true.
You're just living your life.
LOGAN URY: Well, that's
like the spinster bachelor.
MANDY LEN CATRON: Absolutely.
LOGAN URY: I think we need
a new word for single women.
MANDY LEN CATRON: Yeah.
I do, too.
I don't know what it
should be, but I'm
going to think about this.
I want to get in the lexicon.
LOGAN URY: Good.
I'll be on the lookout for it.
So one of the reasons that
the 36 questions I think
is so powerful is
because it creates
space and social permission
for vulnerability.
What are some other ways that
people can foster vulnerability
in romantic and other
interpersonal relationships?
MANDY LEN CATRON: Yeah,
that's such a great question.
I like that you're asking this.
I mean, you don't have
to sit down and do the 36
questions on a date to
generate a sense of intimacy,
but it is a good way to do it.
And you should try
it if you haven't.
But I do think that we have this
idea, especially when dating,
that it's our job
to present our best
selves to the other person.
And in actuality,
people tend to respond
to seeing a little
bit of vulnerability,
like a little bit of weakness.
Or weakness is maybe
not the right word,
but like imperfection.
I think that matters.
And if you look at
OK Cupid's advice
for posting profile
pictures, one
of the things that
they suggest is
that you post a picture
that you yourself think
is not that flattering.
But if you have
a unique feature,
like say you have
a prominent nose--
I think this is the
example that they use--
they're like, you
should have a picture
that really shows that off.
Because actually, some people
are going to really like that,
and you want to cater
to those people.
And I think the same
is true of everything.
And if you go on a date and
you just acknowledge, like,
oh, I'm not a morning person
or whatever-- just revealing
any sort of small
details about yourself
encourages other
people to do the same.
And that slow exchange of
intimacy or vulnerability
can happen in a
less structured way.
LOGAN URY: Do you do
that when you engage
with people, besides Mark?
Do you ever find
yourself saying,
oh, I'm going to
say this thing that
feels authentic and vulnerable
and see if they reciprocate?
MANDY LEN CATRON: I
don't know that I do it
with that level of trying to
get people to reciprocate,
but I do do it.
And one of the things
that I've found--
so when I started doing all
this research, I started a blog.
And what I found
was that the more
sort of vulnerable the
writing was on my own blog,
the more people
responded to it, which
had the effect of making
me feel more comfortable
being vulnerable publicly.
But also, in general, I've just
realized people respond well
to this authenticity.
When you just own who you are,
I think it goes a long way.
So I've become more
comfortable doing it over time.
LOGAN URY: Yeah, I think it's
great advice for everyone.
Sometimes first dates can
feel like a job interview,
and there's so much more
fun when they're not.
MANDY LEN CATRON:
When they're not.
LOGAN URY: So one of my friends
hosted a No Small Talk party.
MANDY LEN CATRON:
Oh, this is cool.
LOGAN URY: Maybe we should
have a No Small Talk first date
rule--
so anyone here who wants
to sign up for that.
MANDY LEN CATRON: I think
that's a great rule, yeah.
Just be really honest
about something
that's important to you.
LOGAN URY: If the person
can find it on LinkedIn,
you don't need to mention it.
MANDY LEN CATRON: Yeah, exactly.
I think that's a good rule.
LOGAN URY: So let me ask you one
more question, and then we'll
have time to open up for
questions from the audience.
We talked about
this a little bit,
but this is a question I
like to ask everyone that I
bring into Google to interview.
We have the google.com
homepage, the white screen
with the logo where people
search billions of times
of the day.
You came up with one idea, but--
MANDY LEN CATRON: Yeah,
I have a real idea.
LOGAN URY: --with one thing
to put on the google.com
homepage related to
dating and relationships,
what would it be?
MANDY LEN CATRON: I
think what it would be is
I think I would
say that love isn't
something that happens to you.
Love is offering yourself with
generosity to another person.
I think that would
be my message.
LOGAN URY: That's so nice.
Great.
So we have a
volunteer who's going
to go around with the mic.
So if you have a question,
just raise your hand,
and he'll get to you.
AUDIENCE: One of my
questions for you is I
feel, especially as a
woman, I'm much more
emotional and vulnerable
and open to talking
about my emotions.
And I definitely want
to talk about or go
through this list of
questions with my boyfriend,
but I'm afraid
he's going to look
at me like I have six heads.
And he's going to
be like, why do you
want to talk all
this emotional stuff?
What's wrong?
And everything is fine.
I just don't think
he'll dig into it.
Maybe Mark is really
that kind of person
that's open to talking
about it, but how
do you talk to a 28-year-old
guy about these deep questions?
MANDY LEN CATRON:
That's a great question.
I mean, I think it's
worth noting that the 36
questions start
out really casually
and they get more
intimate as you go along.
So the first one is, if you
could have dinner with anyone
living or dead, who
would it be, which
I think is just interesting.
And I think maybe if
you just position it
as like a fun game
and a way to get
to know each other--
like, a friend of mine
texted me yesterday
and she said my partner
and I finally did
the 36 questions.
And they have been together
for 15 years or something.
And she's like, I learned
new things about him,
and I was so surprised.
So I think the value
of it sometimes
is just you learn things that
you wouldn't necessarily know.
And it's not like that things
are these necessarily deeply
revealing things.
Sometimes they're just
interesting facts.
And I think if you position
it that way-- it's not like,
hey, let's sit down and talk
about our feelings, which
sometimes Mark and I say to
each other ironically as a way
to actually talk
about our feelings.
Because that feels like a
ridiculous thing to say,
but I think it's
like, oh, hey, look,
I think this would
be fun, let's try it.
Because it is fun.
LOGAN URY: And you can blame us.
You can be like, I went
to this thing at Google.
MANDY LEN CATRON: Totally.
AUDIENCE: You talk about
good relationships,
great relationships,
complicated relationships.
And my question is if you
are in a relationship that
might be complicated and
it might not be great,
do you think that there
is a chance for people
to fall in love again?
Or do you think once things
are broken, they're broken?
MANDY LEN CATRON:
You know, I'm not
very absolute about anything.
I'm sort of wary of
really fixed rules.
So I guess I would say of
course there's a chance.
But I do think we tend to create
these patterns of interactions
with other people, and a lot of
research suggests this as well.
And it's really difficult
to break those patterns,
but I do think it is
possible to change things.
This is like another tip related
to your question earlier.
So John Gottman, famous
relationship psychologist,
talks about basically having
a relationship bank account,
and you want to always
keep it in the block.
And he suggests that you need
like five positive interactions
for every one
negative interaction,
and he has lots of ways
to and incorporate these
into a relationship.
But really, you can practice
positive interactions,
and you can train yourself
to do more of them.
And getting that
ratio up I think
goes a long way towards
relationship satisfaction.
And so it's just little things
like touching your partner
on the shoulder and being
like, hey, how was your day
or saying, thank you.
Thank you goes a long way--
and just like thanks
for taking out the trash
or doing the laundry
or whatever--
just little, small,
positive interactions.
So I think, yeah,
everything's changeable.
AUDIENCE: I have two
if that's all right.
One's just a quick one.
You mentioned a word, I
think "amato normativity."
Spellcheck or spelling
on that would be good,
so I can Google it.
MANDY LEN CATRON: Yeah.
It's a-m-a-t-o
n-o-r-m-a-t-i-v-i-t-y.
LOGAN URY: She's an
English professor.
MANDY LEN CATRON: I always get
nervous spelling things aloud,
because I'm like, the
stakes are high being
an English professor.
LOGAN URY: Google has good--
it would help you.
MANDY LEN CATRON:
Amato normativity.
It's spelled exactly
like it sounds.
AUDIENCE: Got it.
That was my guess,
so made me feel good.
And so the main question is that
there is a concept or this idea
that everyone is our
mirror, and there's a saying
that if you can
spot it, you got it.
And relationships fail when
we see in others qualities
that we dislike about
ourselves, and similarly,
if you admire someone, it's
because you see something
in them that you
have yet to own.
So my question is, is that B.S.?
Do you ascribe to that, or
what are your thoughts on that?
It's kind of like a how do you
fall in love with yourself type
question.
MANDY LEN CATRON:
That's interesting.
I'm not sure what I think
about that, to be honest.
I mean, I do think being in a
relationship with someone who
likes you makes you
like yourself more,
and I do think liking your
partner goes a long way.
I mean, I don't think we
talk about liking enough.
We talk about loving a lot, but
we don't talk that much about
liking.
And there's this thing
that psychologists
have written about called the
Michelangelo effect, which
is really if you see
the best in your partner
that they will aspire to become
the person you see in them.
And that goes both ways.
So if your partner
sees the best in you,
then you will aspire to be
the person that they imagined.
So I suspect that
there's a huge benefit
in noticing the great
things about your partner
and paying attention to
them and complimenting them.
And this is something that I try
to do in my relationship a lot,
and it's also just nice
to be complimented.
So I would say be
in a relationship
with someone who
notices the good in you,
and notice the good
in other people.
LOGAN URY: Is that advice,
though, that you've
given other people,
where you say,
you have to love yourself before
you can be in a relationship?
MANDY LEN CATRON: Yeah, I
don't know if that's true.
I kind of feel like
that's crappy advice,
because there are
plenty of people
who don't love
themselves, who probably
have a lot of self-loathing
who are in relationships.
Obviously, it's great
to love yourself,
but I think it is much
easier to love yourself
when you're with
someone who likes you.
And I've been in
relationships with people
I loved who love me that I'm not
sure we liked each other that
much.
AUDIENCE: Just to follow up
on your previous answers,
you said there are a lot of
people who loathe themselves
who are in relationships.
Do you think they're in
healthy, good relationships?
MANDY LEN CATRON: I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't know if I'm ready
to answer this question.
Because I think it's
really interesting,
but my instinct is that the
answer to this should be no.
But I don't really
know if that's true.
So I'd have to do a little
research to figure that out.
To what extent does
liking yourself
make you happy in
your own relationship?
It probably goes fairly far.
I'm sure it makes a difference.
That's an unsatisfying answer.
I just want to get it right.
So I don't know.
LOGAN URY: Maybe
we'll submit it.
MANDY LEN CATRON: Yeah,
submit it to my advice column,
and I'll do some research
and I'll write about this.
Because I would actually
like to know this answer.
AUDIENCE: If you could have
dinner with anyone, living
or dead, who would it be?
MANDY LEN CATRON:
You know what's
so funny is I was looking over
the 36 questions recently,
and it's been, like, three
years since we did them.
And I realized, I don't
remember any of my answers
or Mark's answers,
or I remember a few.
But that one I couldn't
remember the answer,
so I decided that I needed
to come up with an answer.
And actually, I
decided it would be
my dad's mother, my grandmother,
who died when I was 13.
Because I was able to interview
my mom's mom, my grandmother,
about her love story for
this book and write about it.
She has a fantastic love story.
She met my grandfather.
So they lived in this
tiny, little coal mining
camp in rural Appalachia, like
in the hollers of Virginia.
And she met my
grandfather when he
was on leave from World War II.
And she was 13 and he was 29.
I know.
And they spent two weeks
together just chatting,
and then he went back to
France and fought in Normandy.
And then he came home and was
like, well, let's get married.
And that was two years later.
So she was 15 and he was
31 when they got married,
and then they had
eight children.
And he died when I was four,
and she never remarried.
Anyway, it's such an
interesting story to me,
and I loved talking
to her about it.
So I'd love to be able to
interview my other grandmother
and find out her love story.
AUDIENCE: Kind of going
back to the question
about if you don't like yourself
but you're in a relationship--
I'm more interested
in how would you
go about-- what's your process
for making a study like that?
Do you just find
couples in relationships
and ask them, do you hate
yourself but love this--
I'm curious, actually, how would
you run any of your studies
that you do for research
and do research for this?
MANDY LEN CATRON: I
don't do these studies.
So what I would do is I would
turn to one of my friends
who's a psychologist
and say, can you
do this study and
I'll write about it?
But I think there are ways
for measuring self-esteem,
and there are ways for measuring
relationship satisfaction.
Psychologists have
created tools for this,
and I guess you would
just compare those two.
But I'm not a psychologist,
so I don't know.
I just read a lot of psychology.
LOGAN URY: Just to give
you an example if you're
curious around the
background-- so they
could likely do a
longitudinal study
where they could track a
series of people over something
like four years,
and then they would
say, how much do
you like yourself
and how happy is
your relationship?
And they could track
it and they could
see this person consistently
didn't like themselves
and they consistently
had these relationships.
This person, when they
started to like themselves,
we saw these changes.
And then if there was a
statistically significant
difference, they might be
able to say something like,
when people like
themselves they start to be
in healthier relationships.
MANDY LEN CATRON: See, we
have a psych major here.
She's very handy.
AUDIENCE: My question
would be, what makes
a great relationship great?
And what is the difference
with a good relationship?
Is it all the
emotional connection?
MANDY LEN CATRON: What makes
a great relationship great--
so I've thought
about this a lot,
and I think the short
answer is kindness.
So much of the psychological
research on romantic love
can be summarized as
being kind to someone
and having them be kind to you.
So I think a good rule for
gauging a relationship is, am I
able to be kind to my partner?
And are they kind to me?
And I think if the answer
to either of those questions
is no, then you should
really think about why
you're in that relationship.
AUDIENCE: After your
talk, I realized we mainly
discuss about the relationship
between two people,
but often in the
actual real world
it's like, I come from my
family and my girlfriend also
comes from a family.
And I guess at certain
points, she would ask me,
hey, maybe it's time
for us to get married.
Maybe it's not herself,
maybe just some pressure
from her family,
something like that.
I'm not sure in that
situation how should
I talk with her
about that point.
Because I myself, I
feel like maybe we
should slowly get in that stage
and then maybe get married.
But what if her family-- hey,
it's time for us to get a baby
or for some biological
reason, maybe you
should get a baby as soon as
possible, something like that?
I'm not sure how would
you deal with that case
if your girlfriend is
coming up with that issue.
MANDY LEN CATRON: Yeah,
I mean, I don't know.
But I think what you're asking
a really important question,
and it's important
to acknowledge what's
at the heart of
this question, which
is that love is very much not
just a feeling but a practice.
And that practice is
very much controlled
by our social environments.
And that can be everything
from our immediate family
to a religious belief to
a cultural background,
and all of these things
indicate how people
think about romantic love.
My dad grew up in
the rural South,
and he has really traditional
ideas about love-- traditional
as in the past 100
years, I guess,
how it's been
practiced in America.
And so he is waiting
for my partner
to decide that he
wants to marry me,
and I'm like, that's not
how our relationship works.
But it's really difficult
to cross that cultural gap.
AUDIENCE: Actually
what my [INAUDIBLE]..
MANDY LEN CATRON:
Yeah, so I don't
think I have a good answer
for how to deal with this,
but my advice would be to seek
out stories and experiences
from other people who've
been in this situation.
Because really, if we
think love stories give us
scripts and scripts tell
us how we can possibly
behave in a given
number of situations,
then gathering as many of
those scripts as possible
will give you more options
for how you might handle it.
AUDIENCE: So more [INAUDIBLE]?
MANDY LEN CATRON:
Yeah, basically.
AUDIENCE: So it seems like
in relationships today,
the key metric to
success is longevity,
and I was wondering if you
subscribe to that metric.
And also, so you were talking
about marriages today,
that there's a
modern phenomenon--
relatively modern
phenomenon-- of marriages
being very passionate
and romantic.
And so if longevity
is a good metric,
do we have to redefine
our idea of what
marriage should be like?
MANDY LEN CATRON:
So first I'll say
I don't know that
longevity is a good metric.
I don't think of it
as a good metric.
I guess I feel
complicated about it.
Because like you were saying
this is your anniversary
and I was like,
congratulations--
LOGAN URY: Only of having
lunch at Big Table.
MANDY LEN CATRON:
And so I was thinking
about I have this impulse
to congratulate people,
and yet longevity
doesn't really tell you
anything about the quality
of our relationship at all.
I know people
who've been married
for a very long time who
don't seem particularly
happy to be together.
And so I do think
we would benefit
from coming up with better
metrics, kindness being one.
And what was the second
part of your question?
AUDIENCE: Well, based on the
premise of longevity being
a good metric, do we have to
redefine how we see marriage
in terms of cash-in?
MANDY LEN CATRON:
And I will say I
do think we need to redefine it
regardless, because the fact is
we live in a culture,
like it or not,
that values
long-term commitment.
And really, most people aspire
to long-term commitment,
and I don't think that's
going to change anytime soon.
So I do think we would
benefit from changing
our expectations of marriage for
sure or long-term relationships
in general.
There is this
research that shows--
it's by this psychologist
named Eli Finkel,
and he's found that,
essentially, marriage
has climbed over
the past, I don't
know, 60, 70 years--
or maybe even
longer than that-- climbed
Maslow's hierarchy of needs.
I don't know if you guys
are familiar with us,
but it's basic needs
like food, shelter.
And then it's like
belonging and love,
and then it's self-actualization
up at the top.
And what we increasingly want
and expect from our marriages
is self-actualization.
So we're looking
to this one person
to give us the best
sex we've ever had
and be like a perfect
parent and to have
stimulating conversations about
the latest Malcolm Gladwell
book.
And so it's like we want all
these things from this one
person, and essentially,
what he suggests
is that's really unrealistic.
And we would benefit
from diversifying
the ways in which
we meet those needs
for self-actualization so we're
getting them from other people.
The other really interesting and
not so good side effect of that
is that the best
marriages are probably
more happy and satisfied
than ever before,
but fewer and fewer
people are achieving
that sort of pinnacle
of self-actualization
within a marriage.
And one of the things
that he's pointed out
is that increasingly
satisfaction in marriage
is only accessible to
people of upper-middle class
and upper class, because it
requires-- like this date
night, which I was
saying is so great,
but it requires
financial flexibility
to be able to do
something like that.
Especially if you
have children, you
need to be able to
hire a babysitter,
or you need to not be working
65 hours a week or whatever.
So having the time to invest--
like the more you invest
in your relationship,
the more you get out of it--
but having the time and
resources to do that,
not that many people have that.
So on the whole, I think we
need to really rethink marriage,
but that'll be another book.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
My name is Ricardo, and I
believe you mentioned earlier
that you've seen
relationships where
you're in love
with another person
but maybe you don't
like them right now
or every or something.
And I was wondering,
what do you think
keeps the love alive in
such kinds of relationships
when you just don't
like your partner?
MANDY LEN CATRON: I don't know.
That's a great question.
Why do we stay in
relationships with people
we don't like that much?
I don't know.
I mean, I think maybe I
can only speak for myself
on this particular point.
And I definitely stayed in
a relationship with somebody
who I really, deeply loved.
Like, I felt this strong
sense of intimacy,
and there was a lot
of physical attraction
of shared history.
And the problems is we were
really critical of each other
all the time, and
criticism has been shown
to really erode relationships.
So I think it was
really a matter of time,
but I think part of what kept me
in that relationship, or maybe
even both of us, was the
sense that we had already
invested a lot.
I don't know if you're familiar
with the economic theory
of sunk costs.
It's like you've already
paid for these tickets
to the baseball game, and
even though you have a cold,
you're like, I'm going to go
to this baseball game anyway,
even though I'd rather stay
home and watch a movie.
So I think it's like I'm going
to stick out this relationship
because I've been
in it for so long,
and the work of finding a new
partner is really intimidating
and the other side
feels like very unknown.
And if not perfect,
it's like it's familiar.
And I think that that sort
of inertia is powerful.
It's scary to end
a relationship.
LOGAN URY: Well,
Mandy, thank you
so much for being vulnerable
with us and coming.
It was really great
to talk to you.
MANDY LEN CATRON:
Thanks for having me.
This was so much fun.
LOGAN URY: Yeah.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]